(upbeat music)
- I got it. So while
you're strap- go back.
That right there, yeah.
- Nailed it!
- I mean, I think we nailed it.
- [Billy] Where are we flying to?
(group chuckles)
- I don't-
(flotation device sputters)
- There it is. Yep.
I actually need help.
No, I really-
- [Kevin] You gotta pop it.
- There's so many
snacks. Nope, hands down.
Hands down. First class only, sir.
- Let me get a pretzel.
- No, it's delicious. You can have one.
I lied.
And speaking of liftoff,
be sure to catch our new movie, "Lift."
- Oh, I see what you did there.
- This is the kind of genius,
Gugu would've saw it if
she didn't storm off.
- She can't go that far.
- [Kevin] Yeah, well. Okay.
(Bleep)
That's, that's it?
- Are we done?
- [Kevin] Yeah, we nailed it.